Jimmy Fallon
Jimmy Fallon was always my favorite of
the new crop of late night hosts he he
seemed to be the least
overtly hostile to conservatives the
most fun the most entertaining
certainly the most talented
Jimmy Fallon has just
play the clip
but this latest variant might be the
best
[Music]
19 has arrived
strange but it isn't the same sounds
more like Elon musk's name
[Music]
is 40 who sees Red Red Wine put on your
Maps when you're inside a facility it
could be a robot from a Star Wars
Trilogy it's xcp Point 1.5 not OMG or
MP3 or tcpy or an eye chart made by a
really high God sounds like the password
of your parents Wi-Fi 1.5
[Music]
1.5
so I'm always trying to see the good in
things it's hard to see the good and
that absolutely cringe-inducing
performance
but are we are we at least now admitting
that covet is a total joke is that what
we're I guess that's what we're doing
now
because you don't you don't do little
song and dance routines about serious
illnesses you don't do a song and dance
routine
some people have AIDS
h-i-v and AIDS AIDS AIDS you don't you
don't see late night hosts doing that
you don't see people singing songs and
dance routines about cancer or about
about serious illnesses but they they do
now sing song and dance routines about
covid hahaha there's another round of
kovid
which is fine I think it's fine to make
light even of things that cause some
suffering and inconvenience and and even
even things that really
are quite unpleasant
but the regime the the ruling political
order locked down our country for two
and a half years over this thing they
locked down our country they said it was
so serious that we had to take
unprecedented action to destroy
businesses closed churches have our
loved ones die alone destroy your career
or kick you out of the army kick you out
of your health care job kick you out of
school
because of how serious kovid was and
then up just kidding kovid haha
it's a joke don't you get it why aren't
you laughing with me he he it reminds me
of when Stephen Colbert on his own late
night show decided to do a song and
dance routine about the covet vaccine
remember this so there's Colbert
I actually shouldn't downplay his talent
either I was saying Jimmy Fallon was
obviously the most talented
you see you see Stephen Colbert's a very
good dancer he's actually a very funny
physical performer even though he's a
tedious live when he speaks
and it's Colbert they're dancing around
with people dressed up as giant syringes
which is a different kind of joke by the
way than the joke that Jimmy Fallon was
making
in a way Stephen Colbert's though
equally cringy possibly even cringier
was more justifiable because Stephen
Colbert was making light of the vaccine
everyone was nervous about the vaccine
we now know rightly so because the
vaccine was not effective in the way
that we were told it would be effective
and the vaccine was not safe in the way
that we were told it would be safe so
people had legitimate fears about it and
the establishment propaganda went into
full force to convince people oh it's
not a big deal so if you do a song and
dance routine of oh tihihi it's just a
funny little vaccine don't worry it's a
shot it's no big deal that makes some
more sense
now the establishment propaganda has
become even more egregious which is that
they're telling you to laugh and giggle
about the virus that they just recently
had told you was so serious you had to
lock down your whole life and and put
your whole life on pause or worse
because of it
why is Jimmy Fallon doing this
either it means
that Jimmy Fallon is just chilling the
talking points that the powers that be
want him to Shell which is possible
I don't think he's some hard leftist but
he's a nice guy go along to get along
kind of guy he'll rub Donald Trump's
hair when it's when it's
funny and then he'll also sound like a
big lib when it's funny too so it could
be that or the scariest possibility
is that
Libs and conservatives actually live
according to
tally different perceptions of reality
if the libs actually believe that that
kind of performance is funny the
performance of covid or the vaccine
dance or anything like that then putting
aside our views about
a particular set of lockdown policies or
anything like that it means that our
perception of reality is just totally
different because I there is nothing
less funny there's nothing less
intentionally funny than I've ever seen
than those two performances about coven
but for the libs they they really live
in dread of enthrall of covid and Dr
fauci and they believed all of the
propaganda and all of the nonsense and
so it really might resonate with them
you know the rest of the show continues
now you do not want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles Canada
w-l-e-s at checkout for two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign
[Music]